i will be recommending to cabinet
tomorrow that we continue with plan b
because the public have responded and
changed their behavior changed your
behavior buying valuable time to get
boosters in arms and help the nhs to
cope with the omicron wave
so please carry on observing those
measures for now work from home if you
can
wear face coverings on public transport
and in indoor places and take a test
before you go to a high risk venue or
meet those who are elderly or vulnerable
and of course follow the relevant rules
if you live in scotland or wales or
northern ireland
above all if you haven't already done so
please please get that booster
since i launched the get boosted now
campaign on the 12th of december we've
delivered 10 million extra boosters
across the uk
we've doubled the rate of vaccination
from
000 doses a day to a peak of more than
900 000.
we matched the nhs's previous record day
and then beat it again and again and we
met our target of offering a booster to
every eligible adult a whole month early
but
there are still almost nine million
people eligible who haven't had their
boost and it's absolutely heartbreaking
as many as 90 percent of those in
intensive care with kovid have not had
their booster and over 60 percent of
those in intensive care have not had
with kovid have not had any vaccination
at all
people are dying needlessly because they
haven't had their jabs and they haven't
had that booster and there are two
million booster slots available this
week alone
it's already the case that to travel to
some countries you need a booster to be
considered fully vaccinated
and it's likely that within weeks this
will increasingly become the norm
so
if you haven't done it already get
yourself boosted this month